みんな聞いてくれ
変える方法が
なくだったーー
大事件だ大事件なんだただいま今6本いいにいます今日ちょっと撮影してって朝から朝
から撮影しちゃって事務所に着いたのが23時それからミスト fuck うってなん
かしていると24時になってしまいました
新関西がねぇ2新幹線がないんですけど僕なんか本当に今回はこれでどうしても静岡に
帰りたくてどうしようかなと思ったんですけども
をタクシーで帰る事にしましたうむから静岡の僕の家まで帰ると何円するのか調べて
いこうと思いますもうタクシーの運転手さんに静岡までいいですかっていうのを言っ
たらいいよって言われたんで大丈夫ですでは静岡駅までお願いします
しませんなくてあっん
12:08スタートデー今ちょっとタクシーで親族に帰ってますって言葉酒飲んでも
なんか気にならない事務所からを打つまで9係の買って車で怖いよね
rar
やってきたんですけど
mejiro ん
dj
ん
やったありがとうございます
動画的には高いほうが盛り上がれて
手挽きはなくても大丈夫ですゲームソフト1本ございますねです
[音楽]
[拍手]
だから来た女でもすごいのに
トイレに行ってきますございません
さあこの後ラリマー全然大丈夫ですうーん
ければやったーーー
ええええええ
tan
ここからスレのそうここから盛り上がるとボスぬ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ヌルマン2120円の
はあああ
昔はい
お前いきましょうあーなマンカー
[音楽]
なぜけど思ったほどでしたねじゃあまただよね
なーんだはい
[音楽]
ブーバーさあし
ハーイてくれます
それん
[音楽]
高い
dea
me
ana あああっ